quand même impressionnant c'est la
première fois qu'ils découvrent la salle
vers laquelle sera tourné jeudi soir
l'attention de millions de canadiens
waouh c'est bon c'est beau c'est bon
passionné de politique patrice roy
animateur de la soirée en a vu et vécu
des débats à seulement 11 jours du vote
celui ci sera particulier c'est la
dernière impression
la première impression est important
dans tout la dernière impression est
importante aussi légendaire il confirme
ce que je croyais au bien au non au
contraire je trouve ça pas été bon alors
oui c'est important et pour les chefs
pour tous les chefs ici pour des raisons
différentes c'est un débat qui est
important et ça s'est remplie même décor
même lieu que le débat anglophone de
lundi le théâtre du musée canadien de
l'histoire de gatineau presque à l'ombre
du parlement richard desjardins et le
grand chef d'orchestre de l'événement
une centaine de techniciens travaillent
avec lui c'est un gros mois à 32 ans ce
métis et c'est le plus gros de provins
qu'on avait à faire
c'est un homme le débat anglophone a eu
sa part de critiques notamment parce que
les échanges entre les six chefs ont
donné lieu à des moments cacophonique
mais le concept du débat francophone
était différent dès le départ un citoyen
qui vont venir poser une question avant
chaque thème les chefs auront très peu
de temps pour répondre ensuite deux
débats ouverts des trios il y aura un
débat ouvert à la toute fin
des journalistes invités pourront aussi
une question au chef patrice roy le sait
six chefs qui débattent cinq thèmes
différents en deux heures ce sera tout
un défi à gérer je n'hésiterai pas à les
rappeler à l'ordre
il faut que ce débat soit compréhensible
un débord c'est un moment clé d'une
campagne électorale
donc ma pain par exemple on s'est réuni
tout le groupe et on a revu ensemble de
nos questions au prince est extrêmement
au sérieux alors son exercice important
et c'est très très impressionnant bête
le débat francophone sera diffusée par
une vingtaine de médias au canada en
trois roulements ici jean-sébastien
cloutier radio-canada gatineau